eilmeldung die politik hat ein völlig
neues phänomen entdeckt dass außer rund
vier millionen deutschen wirklich noch
keiner auf dem zettel hatte hartz4 ist
gar nicht mal so geil wahnsinn
grüne und spd überbieten sich jetzt
gegenseitig mit hartz4 reformvorschlägen
man nennt das willy brandt haus schon
das haus auf hartz iv
dabei hat andrea nahles doch noch im
april gesagt sie will keine
rückwärtsgewandten debatten über hartz
iv
woher der plötzliche sinneswandel das
hat etwas damit zu tun dass wir
festgestellt haben im jetzigen hartz4
regime ist es so dass wir durchaus durch
sanktionen tatsächlich menschen unter
das existenzminimum drücken hört doch
auf wirklich das ist euch jetzt
aufgefallen
toll was zwei vergeigte landtagswahlen
für denkprozesse auslösen können ja mein
reden seit jahren den leuten die würden
neben reicht nicht du musst ihn auch das
wahlrecht nehmen sonst bestrafen sind
nicht an der urne
ja ja
habt ihr erst aufgehört ja das ist die
erkenntnis des herzens deswegen will
robert habeck von den grünen sogar 30
milliarden für einen menschenwürdigen
hartz-iv-satz ausgeben und sanktionen
streichen dieser leistungsträger hier
kann es nicht fassen der reifig
milliarden euro zusätzliche
steuereinnahmen und das gilt geld will
herr habeck dann nutzen um es zu geben
denjenigen die nicht arbeiten wollen
genau 4,1 millionen deutsche wollen
nicht arbeiten
ich frage mich gerade wer war noch mal
dieser eine faule sack der seine
arbeitsverweigerung mit dem satz
begründet hat lieber gar nicht regieren
als falsch
[Applaus]
ich komme nicht drauf aber wunderschön
das weiß ich noch hartz4 gilt als
existenzminimum
trotzdem darf das amt immer wieder bei
verstößen davon noch ordentlich was
kürzen und das trifft dann leider oft
die falschen ganz schön oft wie diesen
mann der morgens behinderte kinder zur
schule fährt und ich haben sie immer so
um 37 bestellt obwohl die eigentlich
wussten dass ich in mini job hatte und
trotzdem haben sie mich dann halt zu den
uhrzeiten bestellt und war ich da nicht
hingegangen bin haben sie mich deswegen
funktioniert heißt in dem fall sie haben
ihm tatsächlich 100 prozent seiner kohle
gestrichen
christian lindner gefällt dass das
system der sanktionen stellt alle hartz
4 empfänger unter generalverdacht warum
werden menschen 80 jahren arbeit genauso
gestellt wie einer der nie gearbeitet
hat in deutschland leben allein zwei
millionen kinder von stütze da gibt es
zum geburtstag höchstens meine hardware
kirschtorte 296 euro regelsatz für ein
zehnjähriges kind davon 50 cent für
bildung und zwar pro monat
das reicht nicht mal für die bild
zeitung soviel zur sozialen hängematte
in wirklichkeit des harz eine endlose
kette von demütigungen plus
galoppierender bürokratie irrsinn hier
jetzt nicht im heute-show fanshop
christoph maria herbst ließ das
komplette sozialgesetzbuch zwei
grundsicherung für arbeitsuchende
paragraf 21 mehrbedarfe der mehrbedarf
ist unabweisbar wenn er insbesondere
nicht durch die zuwendungen dritter
sowie unter berücksichtigung von
einsparmöglichkeiten der
leistungsberechtigten gedeckt ist und in
seiner höhe nach erheblich von einem
durchschnittlichen bedarf abweichen wow
das versteht ihr wirklich gerne so
erfahren sie auf den cds zwei bis sieben
wie viel warmwasser ihnen als hartz4
empfänger zu steht ein mehrbedarf wird
anerkannt so weit warmwasser durch in
der unterkunft installierte
vorrichtungen erzeugt wird und deshalb
keine bedarfe für zentral bereitgestellt
das warmwasser nach § 22 anerkannt
werden und als highlight unsere bonus-cd
christoph maria herbst sind § 20 riegel
bedarf bestellen sie jetzt sonst rutscht
christoph maria herbst inhalts vier ab
wir nutzen und sich hartz iv empfänger
zahlen dasselbe
[Musik]
ja
super herrlich
ganz tolles hörbuch ideal für die
wartezeit im jobcenter
ja man hat sich halt irgendwie gewöhnt
an hartz 4 über die jahre genau wie an
die vielen aufstocker die so schlecht
bezahlt sind dass der staat zuschießen
muss ja das sind mal so subventionen
über die man sich aufregen könnte hartz
4 und niedriglöhne hängen nämlich
zusammen in diesem sinne herzlich
willkommen so nennen die holsten von den
sprit wirklich schmutzige wahrheit über
[Applaus]
juni aus und jetzt schauen wir endlich
mal der nackten ungeschminkten wahrheit
in ihre hässliche fresse und ich habe
keine ahnung warum ich dich treiben
geduldiger denn wie heißt es immer so
schön hartz4 und die agenda 2010 waren
da grünstein deutsche aufschwung
ich könnte mir an dieser stelle mal ein
zynisches hohen gelöscht
die frage wäre hat hartz4 nicht
irgendwie doch die deutsche
arbeitslosigkeit quasi halbiert
nein korrigiert jetzt war es ein kleines
wäldchen die mainstream ökonomen haben
bei den arbeitslosenzahlen einfach immer
das jahr 2005 mit 2016 zyklischen kommst
du noch mit ja ja ich war aber das ist
weder falls wörter sagt ich kann nie
vergleichen immer 2005 rezessionen 2016
haben wir können das haben wir
[Applaus]
das steht bei den deutschen hoch 2001
das war ein boomjahr
wenn du das mit 2006 vergleichen ist da
ist die zahl der arbeitslosen nicht um
1,2 millionen sondern nur und 340.000
gesunden haben wir hier
ich kann dir gleich mal zeigen was hat
hier das schaffen
die zahl der menschen die arbeiten und
trotzdem von armut bedroht sind hat in
deutschland seit den hartz-reformen um
100 prozent zugenommen so viel wie in
keinem anderen eu land so jetzt sind wir
nämlich an dem punkt wo der elefant das
wasser lässt bei hartz4 den haut von dem
die zwingt jeden job anzunehmen haben
wir heute den größten niedriglohnsektor
in ganz westeuropa not rosner zeit und
besonders gekniffen sind motorisch wie
immer die frage
die finanzielle situation ist für
alleinerziehende frauen wesentlich
dramatischer also armut ist immerhin
weidlich ja klar das ist ja auch die
armut und nicht mehr
es heißt übrigens auch der tritt in die
eier 36 prozent der alleinerziehenden
mütter kriegen hartz4 sich ein kind
oströhre quetschen ist in deutschland
armutsrisiko innere uhr hier eine
betroffene packt aus sie weiß was es
bedeutet mutter von drei kleinen kinder
zu sein
das ist völlig aus
die frau die wir gerade gesehen haben
die ist übrigens erst ende dreißig jahre
aber vom leben gezeichnet hat als er es
ja gar nicht lustig das ist ja ein
echtes problem
alleinerziehende also wenn es eine frau
nicht schafft dass der mann bei ihr
bleiben
duscha mirage aber geht's doch
alleinerziehende frauen später im
schnitt 58 prozent weniger rente als
männer
verheiratete kriegen ehegattensplitting
baukindergeld und was sehe ich stets mit
dem kleinen mal mit wenn du mich hasst
du dumme sau wird auf die kommt sehr gut
ohne dich geh denken wir daran wenn du
deine billige kleineren durch dunst wenn
die hausfrau
[Applaus]
[Musik]